fortunately that heartbreaking story
isn't the only tragedy to come out of
the windy city this weekend as the
carnage continues on the streets of
chicago between friday and sunday there
were 54 shooting incidents wounding 86
and killing 13 people now our outraged
residents are asking where is the mayor
lori lightfoot as the city spires out of
control
under her watch brittany benson knows
the true cost of lifeless failure as her
15-year-old son demarion was gunned down
on the city streets last month and
another example of the senseless
violence
brittany benson joins me now along with
violence interrupter executive director
t.o hardiman uh brittany can you tell me
the story of your son demarion when you
got that phone call
what did you do
well what happened was i talked to
demaryon about 5 53.
he had asked me what i was doing and i
told him i was cooking and he was like
oh yeah oh yeah i'm coming home i'm like
well you know come home cause you know
we got to take care of some important
business
he was like
i ma i love you mom
and that was the last time i spoke with
him so
it had to be like around like 6 11. my
mom was calling me back to back
so i didn't pick up i'm like maybe she
didn't want nothing at that moment i
wasn't thinking and so
my sister-in-law called me she was like
tell me this not true me
i'm like what did you what are you
talking about so
my sister called me she was like she was
crying she was like where you at mimi
astrological hospital so you know i
guess the australia hospital and i knew
something was wrong because at that
moment
it felt like
my stomach
was caving in and they feel like i had
to regurgitate it it was weird and it
just
it felt awkward like i knew something
was wrong and then
30 minutes later they told me he was
deceased
brittany you said that he was your eyes
yes i was born with um a condition
called congenital glaucoma
and he was everything
and he was his mama's eyes um i want to
go to uto you have been on the streets
for a while talking with the community
trying to bring
uh some type of justice in that city
what do you think it would take right
now to end the violence in chicago
well first i just want to send my
condolences out to officer uh french and
her family and also with brittany what i
plan to do here is assign five of my
staff to brittany 24 hours a day to help
her you know take her to the store
because she lost her son her son serves
served as another set of eyes for her so
i plan to allow some of my staff to take
her to the growth store and help her
when she runs errands number one and uh
number two i just want to say this what
it what it will take to really stop the
gun violence in chicago we need to
pretty much assemble a big unit of
african-american men that are really
concerned about these young guys out
here and we need to swarm the community
in big big numbers and actually bring
them guys to the table of peace and try
to mediate all those conflicts out there
with them young guys because the young
guys are looking for help but instead
they're shooting and killing killing one
another because they don't know how they
do not know how to resolve conflicts out
there so it turns deadly t.o uh i've
been to chicago several times
talked with the young brothers talk with
the community try to get the mayor on
the record and one thing that i have
noticed is that these young people
aren't being given a choice anymore the
the violence is ruling the city it's
either you join the gangs or you die now
and so you're not just going after the
the drug dealers and the gang members on
the street you're going after the people
that are responsible for converting
these young minds they don't have a
choice anymore tio
well people have to understand worldwide
the gun violence problem in chicago
baltimore new orleans memphis st louis
is cultural and it's tribal if you do
not address the culturalism with the gun
violence because people are conditioned
to respond a certain way here when it
comes to gun violence so all the experts
out there in the field they do not
understand the culture and the history
of the gun violence with
african-american people and i say this
because over 80 percent of the gun
violence occurs in the african-american
community but today this interview is
about britney so i'm not going to take
up much more time if you don't mind
because i want britney it's all about
brittany benson today yeah i appreciate
that brittany i want to go back to you
um if you had the opportunity to talk to
the mayor
the d.a and all the elected officials
that are representing chicago what would
you tell them
what i would tell them is they need to
do better i don't have no problem with
mayor lightfoot i think she's a nice
person i don't know her personally but
i feel like she could do better but it's
like how could she do better when all
this stuff is
going on in the communities
yeah
so often tio
it is being said that kim fox the d.a is
allowing these offenders to be back out
no bail
they put an ankle bracelet on them and
they commit the crimes again
what would you say to her
well that's what happens when you make
decisions from the mountaintop and
you're not interviewing and talking to
the people down in the valley a lot of
people have been released from prison
well put on put it like this they've
been released from the county jail on
electronic monitoring some of the guys
have uh repeat offenders gun offenders
so when you when they are released they
go out and shoot and kill somebody while
they're while they're out on bond or
electronic monitoring that's not right
so kim fox should stop making decisions
from the mountaintop come down in the
valley and talk to the victims of crime
like brittany benson lost her 15 year
old son and right now in chicago over
100 young people under 15 years old have
been
shot in chicago and so far to date over
460 people have been killed in chicago
over 2 600 people shot to date it makes
no sense that's what's going on in
chicago we need a total new uh strategy
to be implemented here in chicago right
now well i tell you brother i appreciate
the work that you do miss benson i want
you to know that you're loved and i as
long as i'm at fox news i will continue
to cover these stories i will continue
to show up in chicago and highlight this
because it matters to me that could have
been me that could have been someone
that i love in chicago and it has a stop
and i know a lot of people watching this
show feel the same way thank you all so
much for coming on the program tonight
appreciate you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else